I did not submit myself they came to me
and I turned it down but my daughter
Aleta
of Morgan because she's here in the film
industry in LA and she insisted that I
go ahead and do the strain test so we
went to Philadelphia Ashley and I and
the DES screen test there at a comic
convention but I was chosen by Harry
Knowles from a Nakul Tom Perry's father
and mother and I were stoner hippies
together in Austin back in the early 70s
and they used to let me sleep in their
attic when I was living in my car
oh no you never give up I've sold a
hundred and fifty million dollars in
comics since I was living in my car but
it has never been any big score it's
been a three dollar comic here $100
there five dollar comic there what you
do is you succeed in this world by
giving other people great service
because then they come back and they
want to be your friend they want to do
business with you some more and I think
that that's what it's all about
sometimes it gets harder because you
know and sometimes there's a shrinking
pond and no matter how good a job you do
you're no better than your context but
if you do good works you can always
succeed you just can't give up though
you got just keep going to keep trying
well I didn't really feel any need for
the exposure I guess that's the way to
put it and I thought that maybe someone
else but since I got involved with
Morgan I realized that I was being
really foolish because working with him
and working with guys that are on our
group was just incredible this is such a
fantastic experience and I learned so
much that I I was really being though oh
very very happy it's very quick
you